welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and what is the real Mission and
who is the real villain of Loki season
2. this show aims to revisit the early
days of the TVA and Kang's timeline
manipulation with the variant of Victor
timely presenting his temporal Marvels
at the 1893 World's Fair in Chicago one
of the timeline targets Loki Mobius will
be investigating the focus of that visit
seems to be Kang's mystery Marvel itself
a specific piece of technology that Loki
Mobius OB and B15 need to Abate the
Multiverse crisis that Sylvie left them
in but we need to talk about what
exactly this machine is and how using it
could leave Loki and the others in an
even bigger crisis is Kang or Richter
timely even the villain of Loki season 2
or is there someone else in the shadows
that this trailer hasn't even shown us
yet quick reminder that sag-aftra has
informed us that entertainment
journalists like new rockstars are
allowed to cover movies and TV shows yet
we support the actors and the writers
and their strike we joined the call to
the amptp to return to the table to
reach a fair agreement okay the
post-credits scene of Ant-Man the watch
quantumania previewed a scene from this
upcoming season of in which Loki and
Mobius visit the 1893 Chicago World's
Fair in which one of the exhibits is
Victor timely a Kang variant and a
Nikolai Tesla style presentation of what
he calls his temporal Marvels timely
says hi is everything
it shapes Our Lives
but perhaps
we can shape
it and this new trailer shows timely
igniting this device which is fanned out
into about a half a dozen parts that
later sparked together in bolts of
purple electricity in attendance at this
Expo is of course Loki and Mobius but
also ravana rensslayer or perhaps her
Victorian era variant Rebecca tormente
whose name we saw on her frame diploma
in her office in 2018 Ohio in the season
one finale we also know from Trailer
footage that Sylvie will be recruited
from a record store maybe from another
timeline and that she will be in Victor
timely's Workshop attacking him I think
this device is one of the earliest forms
of technology that Victor timely or the
Kang variant if he remains they might
actually be the same person whoever this
is will use to build the entire TVA
organization I think we're seeing the
origins of the TVA and I think that the
pieces of this instrument if you were to
compile them together do look a bit like
this green device that Mobius is holding
in this one other trailer shot with Obi
Loki and B15 like perhaps if you were to
merge them all together you get what
Mobius is holding based on the light on
their faces I'm wondering if they're
looking out on these sacred timeline
splintering fragmenting exploding and
they're planning on a way to patch it
and reunify it which might temporarily
pause Loki's time slipping everything
changes as you get older the music's too
loud the cars are too fast and your hair
can start to thin but you can hit the
brakes on hair loss by using keeps keeps
offers clinically proven research-backed
treatments to stop hair loss and improve
hair growth all keeps treatment plants
are recommended by a licensed medical
provider and delivered straight to your
door at about half of the cost of a
traditional Pharmacy each treatment plan
comes with a full year of unlimited
messaging so you can connect with your
medical provider about anything anytime
keeps has a network of Expert Medical
advisors prescribers and Care
Specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality two out of
three guys will experience hair loss by
the time they're 35 but with keeps you
can get quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or Pharmacy
whether you're looking to prevent hair
loss stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair that you have
keep says you covered hair loss stops
with keeps to get a special offer go to
keeps.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description that's keps.com
new rockstars I kind of like this idea
of parts of a machine coming together to
form a cryptic MacGuffin because it
reminds me of the algorithm device and
Christopher Nolan's tenant a movie that
I've had on the brain since it
thematically set up Oppenheimer but
you'll notice the device on the far left
and has it looks like five nozzles in a
rotating joint that could be used to
absorb incoming timelines and then twist
them together like rope into one braided
sacred timeline this might be the same
device that we see elsewhere in the
trailer what I've been calling the patch
that is used to weave the chaos of a
Multiverse and unpredictability into one
controlled timeline we could start
calling this a timeline unifier and I
think it's what Victor timely was
referring to when he said perhaps we
couldn't shape it so it seems like at
least in the first or first two episodes
of Loki season 2 Loki to stop his time
slipping we'll reunite with Sylvie from
another timeline go back to 1893 to the
Chicago World's Fair to find Victor
timely's original time line unifier it's
in Portal marble snatch it incur the
wrath of a skirted Ms minutes and then
bring it back to the TVA to try to patch
the Multiverse and it might work but
only temporarily because folks I've
analyzed trailers and Marvel's marketing
practices for the past seven years and I
can tell you this trailer is really just
showing us the first three episodes or
so worth the footage Loki time slipping
reuniting with Sylvie the World's Fair
in Victor timely and Rebecca tormody
some stuff on this temporal Arc of some
kind with lifeboats and then an episode
3 side mission with Brad wolf and zaniac
at a London movie premiere we just saw
the same kind of thing in Loki season 1
trailers there's a lot from the first
two episodes of the show but only brief
Snippets here and there of things like
the void or the Citadel really the irony
of this plan is if Loki and the others
work to patch the broken Multiverse
early on in Loki season 2. that would be
playing right into the second of he
remains two offered options you remember
those that was to either kill him and
unleash his variants or to take his
place and take over the TBA this would
be to take over the TBA to maintain the
sacred timeline in his stead but that is
not what Sylvie chose Sylvie chose the
first option to kill he remains even if
that would risk unleashing his variants
though variance waiting in the wings
from the Kang Dynasty arena in the
quantumania mid-credits scene in the
Soviet we're seeing in this trailer in
the record store the one working at the
McDonald's I don't think it's our
original Sylvie who killed he remains we
don't know where she is I think that's
Sylvie and what she wants a dead he
remains a shattered Multiverse the
ability to whack a mole king after Kang
after King is what this trailer is not
showing us I think Sylvie not Kang but
Sylvie will be the True Villain of Loki
season 2. because when the bigger
casting announcements ahead of this
season who is nowhere to be seen in any
trailer footage so far has been Kate
Dickey perhaps best known for playing
Lady Liza Aaron in Game of Thrones she's
been confirmed to be part of this season
but we do not as of this taping know
what character she is playing I think
she might be playing Sylvie Prime the
Sylvia Sylvie or you could say even the
lokiest Loki technical the Loki
variant's most eager to let the
Multiverse burn if it means that she can
replace Kang the Conqueror as the
ultimate Nexus being I just wonder if it
might be too much to make Kang the
predominant villain of Loki season 2
because Marvel Studios definitely has
bigger plans for the character Beyond
this season and by making Sylvie the
villain of the Season they'll just have
a bit more control over the narrative
and some more flexibility to handle
whatever ends up happening with John of
the majors now I am not saying Marvel
Studios pivoted to swap in Sylvia as a
villain to season two instead of Kang I
think this has always been the plan
really the Loki writers would have had
less than a few weeks to rewrite
anything after Major's legal drama came
out in April 2023 and the WJ went on
strike in May 2023 and we would have
heard more about production being rushed
through ahead of the actor strike in
July I saw the very first Loki teaser
back in September of 2022 at d23 and
much of what we see in this new trailer
is pretty much the same footage they
didn't change much about this this has
always been the plan I'm pretty sure and
ultimately I just think it makes for a
better Loki story to use Sylvie as the
ultimate antagonist because she has
deeper emotional Stakes with the low
Loki variant l1130 and ultimately in the
Loki season 1 finale it really was more
of a Loki vs Silvy battle he remains her
Kang is more of an Emperor Palpatine
Shadow architect of everything he's a
passive Observer looking at the bigger
picture in fact I think Kang being
emotionally detached from everything is
what really made him less effective as a
villain in quantumania and it'll just be
more interesting to see the character as
a villain once we know more about the
Dynasty's history with Heroes like the
Fantastic Four personally I'm just more
excited for Loki to accidentally end up
playing he remains his game and
betraying his soulmate variant who
wanted to break that cycle but I want to
hear from you what do you think Loki's
Mission will be in Loki season 2 and who
do you think will be the final villain
please subscribe to all three channels
in the new rockstars Network you can
follow me on all social platforms at EA
boss thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
thank you